tu sais ce que j'aime dans le fait d'être
Spider-Man, tout Wow Peter, je peux
entrer, non, d'accord, viens ici, viens,
pour l'amour de Dieu, laisse-moi entendre ce qui est arrivé
à ton visage, c'est sale,
tu sais, je nettoyais la cheminée, nous
n'avons pas de cheminée.  ce que
chaque jour je me réveille en sachant que peu
importe le nombre de vies que je protège,
peu importe le nombre de personnes qui m'appellent un héros,
quelqu'un d'encore plus puissant pourrait changer
tout ce que nous avons des projets pour toi Peter
Parker,
tu marque des buts
est plus grand que ton Peter,
j'ai fait un choix  c'est mon pot
allons attraper une araignée
besoin d'un coup de main
ok je dois y aller je viens avec toi le maïs
est trop dangereux désolé je t'aime ne me pends pas
toi